welcome back we're doing the last part
of problem one
of the 2008 calculus bc exam and i'll
repeat the problem it says the region r
models the surface of a small pond at
all points r
at all points in r at a distance
x from the y axis
the depth of the water is given by h of
x is equal to three minus x find the
volume of the water in the bond so we
thought about this is you know a
perspective drawing of this this is the
surface of the pond right here and i was
trying to draw the depth so when x is
equal to zero the pond is
exactly three i guess you know we could
say feet or whatever the units are deep
and then when x is equal to two the pond
is one unit deep
and so to find the volume we think about
it the same way what does the cross
section at any point of the pond look
like
well if we let's see so if we were to
take a cross section
so let's say that this let's take this
cross section of the pond let me do a
different color
and it can be kind of confusing it's not
too different so that's green
so the the height along the surface of
the pond is going to be the difference
between the two functions and we know
that this top function is sine
of pi x
and we know that this bottom function is
x to the third
minus 4x
so if i were to draw
let me see if i can draw this
this cross section
this cross section so we know this the
height i'm sorry the width along the
surface
of this cross section is going to be the
difference between this function
and this function right
so if i were to draw
let me let me see if i can so this is
that same cross section that same cross
section
it's the the height or no sorry the
width along the top i know i'm confusing
you is going to be this function minus
this function so it's going to be
sine
of pi x
minus
x to the third
minus 4x
and what's going to be the height
right here
well they told us the height of the pond
or the depth of the pond at any point is
3 minus x whatever x value you're at so
this is going to be
3 minus x
so the area of this cross section of the
pond is going to be so the area is going
to be
sine
of pi x
minus
x to the third minus 4x
times the depth of the pond right that's
the surface with times the depth so that
times
3
minus x so that's the area of each cross
section so if we want the volume for the
entire pond we take essentially the
volume of each of these kind of slivers
of the pond so we take the area of each
cross section and we multiply it
by a very small width to get a very
small sliver so you take that and
multiply it by dx
dx and we integrate we we sum up all of
these slivers of the pond from x is
equal to zero to x is equal to two
so let's do that let's integrate from x
is equal to zero to x is equal to two
once again this is a really hard
integral or it's it's something that you
can do especially if you use integration
by parts but it's a little bit messy and
you don't you only have 45 minutes to do
all three problems on the bc exam so i'm
assuming that they want you to use the
calculator here so let's use the
calculator
to evaluate it
so let's see
we might be able to use what we so
that's this was part c that we already
have in our calculator we can actually
do second enter and we'll get the
previous entry
second
enter because we already typed in a
bunch of stuff the only difference
between
what we did in part c and now is
now instead of having in part c we had
this expression squared now we don't
have it squared but we're multiplying it
by times three minus x so let's do that
so if we go here
we can delete this squared we're not
squaring it anymore delete it and now
let's do i want you to see my keystrokes
so let's do second insert
so let's insert
times
3
minus
x
close parentheses
and so let's see we have sine of pi x
minus x to the third plus 4x right
that's the same thing as this times 3
minus x
and our variable of integration is x and
we're integrating from x is equal to 0
to x is equal to 2. let's hit enter
and notice that it is calculating and
our answer is 8.37
i think is a fair answer so the volume
this time the volume of the pond is
equal to 8.37
anyway hopefully you found that useful i
will
every day try to do a couple of these
problems see you in the next video